welcome back we continue our team
coverage this afternoon here on all
those storms mary jane bellingham
joining us now live just west of the
strip where traffic signals were out and
mary jane possibly caused by the storm
but boy that does cause drivers some
issues
oh absolutely the traffic signals are
now back on and from lightning heavy
rain and intense flooding from last
night's storm this morning proved to be
a challenge for drivers
the morning commute taking longer for
some friday morning as traffic lights at
numerous intersections across the valley
went out or were flashing red i reached
out to rtc operations i'm told they will
work closely with the city of las vegas
to determine which lights still need to
be fixed throughout the morning many
started working again over at rose
warren elementary near torrey pines and
alta teachers and students arrived to
some wet classrooms moving some to other
rooms while cleanup crews mopped it up
the principal is reporting everyone is
safe viewers like nathan pellegrino
reaching out to 8 news now about street
flooding on farm and virginia del street
due to possible blockage of storm drains
he's also reached out to the water
district so they can get it cleaned out
[Music]
now there were also reports from viewers
of big trees falling over on lake mead
and rancho and that storm potential does
continue through this weekend so if you
see flooding turn around don't drown
reporting from highland and western mary
jane belliesa 8 news now